what if aliens landed on Earth today the
arrival of aliens would raise many
questions about our place in the
universe and the possibility of life
beyond our planet
as they land on Earth the first thing we
would need to do is determine their
intentions how would we communicate with
them they could have entirely different
forms of communication that we would
need to decipher what they bring new
knowledge and technology or a threat to
our very existence depending on their
intentions the arrival of aliens could
have a range of outcomes it would change
everything we know about our place in
the universe and our understanding of
life itself as for how it might happen
scientists believe that the discovery of
extraterrestrial life is only a matter
of time with the discovery of thousands
of exoplanets the likelihood of finding
life beyond Earth has increased
significantly